kill fun vegans real fun oh you didn't
lock it what is it Oh Jess hey good
Monette hi I'm Gregg huh
I'm here today I know that's home
because we were filming an episode of
sweet eats it's a baking channel where
you can learn to be delicious while
being healthy and you get to laugh with
these two yeah which is awesome these
two lovely human beings whose approval I
want go check out their channel ASAP
soon as possible yeah it's good
yep I laugh you have a good time
delicious you want to improve your life
so it's about now on the topic of dating
five strangest scary videos found on the
dark side of YouTube yeah I'm not that
familiar with the dark side of YouTube I
would like to become more familiar with
it this is good information for all of
us in this room Janelle yeah we can all
great benefit greatly from this because
we can you can be aware of what's out
there I fight for the light I'm on the
good the Rebel Alliance it's the dark
side of YouTube team other reaction
channels that's the dark side of YouTube
duration is impressive it's very decided
to compile is the creepy and weird
videos that I've found in the rear part
of YouTube most of the videos that I
hear much information attached to but I
tried my best to find as much
information as I could most of these
videos that included the links in the
description box down below so go ahead
and click it if you dare to number five
the first video that was found I saw an
ad for fantastic it was uploaded on
YouTube by user that goes by the name of
creepy blog basically it's a female
mannequin who is standing in an empty
room in the house possibly the living
room the creepy part about the videos
are treating music that's playing in the
background
all while she's making creepy and
robotic movements the perfect wife the
mannequins figure also add some
creepiness to the video the video is
more strange than scary but it is still
worth of being put in this list number
four okay if you think that the previous
video that I showed to you earlier was
creepy wait till I show you this one
this video was uploaded on December 2nd
2006 by this channel it's not known if
this user was the original class the
video but he named it as kiddie candy
the video starts off for the tricky
message that reads coming soon unsure of
what it relates to then it quickly
transitions to a house and it shows the
back of someone's head fast-forwarding
through the video a cat is randomly
filmed and the same man who previously
appeared in the video begins dumping a
box of cat food kitty cat the whole
video could have possibly meant to be
trippy for targeted audience nonetheless
too spooky for me that's too much dark
energy I like it the clip that's about
70 was uploaded by Maxie Soto on April 7
2006 and zero subscribers videos have
Czech origin the name of the video is
written in a different language but it
directly translates into manly games the
video itself has a lot of weird parts in
it and of course the music once again
plays a part in adding some of the
creepiness to it the setting teacher at
first it seems like a normal video but
you start seeing the city green faces
take a look for yourself was going on it
looks like when we baked earlier touch
that the video that we're going to it's
not for the heavens found out creepy
the video was posting to let me hear
your war I on August 15 2010 the
username this clip ass let me hear your
war cry the original creator of this
video used a portion of the clip from
the 1987 drama film full metal jacket in
this crook you replace the faces of the
soldier with Japanese mannequin masks as
you progress through the video the
screens that can be heard in a
background changes into a higher pitch
which acts the creepy aura here's a
preview of it oh oh no that's like
surely Cranbury oh my god number one
monolith a VI is a creepy video that was
uploaded on YouTube on February 9th 2012
there are probably multiple versions of
this video out there but the one that I
found is about a minute long it starts
off with a person playing with a light
switch and then it cuts up to a random
scene with a camera zooms in into a
mysterious creature that doesn't seem to
be coming from our planet Earth in the
video you can see the camera zooming it
to the creatures face and then it zooms
out the video keeps skipping frames into
a black and white scale effect the video
as a whole is mysterious but it gives
off that chilling vibe at the same time
thank you so much for watching don't
forget to click that like button if you
enjoyed it and don't forget to subscribe
to us from our updates we pulled that
grumpy cat face I don't like that I'm
here buddy hmm
I'm sad to be here why don't they give
advice let's break this down okay yeah
this uh like creepy mannequin lady I saw
a video of this girl who goes out of her
way to like put on this makeup to look
like a mannequin oh my gosh thank me out
yeah yeah some people do like I don't
know cosplay but they just go out like
that like all the time
and I just look like an actual doll it's
freaky there's like there's like a human
Barbie out there it's girl really geeky
nah it could be a better look in the
Barbie my video that's awful man
I'm definitely seen creepier than this
yeah that could be a real person though
doesn't have to just be a mannequin that
could be a real person could be yeah I
could be John John he's skinny enough to
be a mannequin
kitty candy candy candy oh my god that
is so uncomfortable
this was the creepiest one is that a
mannequin too or is that a person I
think that's a person you think that's
the creepiest one yeah I think it's
definitely yeah it's either that or the
face peeling one also oh yeah that was
weird that was really weird I mean this
one is just like screams what I catch
like just do whenever she doesn't think
I'm watching us maybe thing up there
enola with her hands
[ __ ] Jess would she says it changed oh
yeah the peeling hey oh my god it looks
like oh hell who would think of that get
it
table I know it sounds like I was making
a joke but it does look a lot like what
we were begging see buddy is Krisha it's
cinnamon roll another you guys can see
the person what is the point of these
videos exactly I don't know like who who
comes up with these then who watches
them what's it apparently we guess
that's true if I have I came across this
video I would totally be like you got
your watches hahaha craziest [ __ ] I've
ever seen yeah actually a cool way to
kill someone very cool way ripping my
face right right like who's someone you
hate Jesse go feel a hate in yet I hate
anyone [ __ ] Manette who da I don't
hate anyone eat ah [ __ ] um uh Hitler
I hate Hitler I was gonna say Trump so
we can go a shrimp this is a very
political channel subjective our stance
you think of anyone right sometimes I
get annoyed with Mariah Carey but I
forgive her it just annoyed yeah not
genuine hate I've never heard any one
direction songs but their fans kind of
annoy me okay I really this is their
fans
oh if if it was legal but I'm not going
to Illyria
oh the let me hear your war cry that
movie is so intense this feels like a
dream I would have had where I like saw
Japanese horror movie I saw Full Metal
Jacket and then I have this dream I
could say that oh my gosh how's
horrifying anything look doll like
freaks me out
yeah what about clowns hate clowns yeah
well oh I hate clowns
Oh miles I kill clowns there's a there's
a sad depressed clown on third
I'm not all the time oh I can't even I
can't walk past him sad he bought the
sad clown he's just like sit there sad
it's so weird
I'll get the shotgun couple they all
need to be taken out sorry if any clowns
watch this I don't really get the one
with the mom yeah I don't know it kind
of does remind me of my mom whenever I
feel like I'm in like I like it bad like
bad lighting just bad laughing yeah
almost wonderful most beautiful woman
under great light bad lighting that I
uploaded this video or an alien or a
skeleton yeah like a fetus yes feet I
just won well oh I did it there's more
than one huh yeah be way we can do that
effect oh all right let's see how it
comes out Wow tell five unknowns I did
not know about some of these videos I
want to find out who did the kitty cat
Elin thing I have cats and I could use a
cat sitter sometimes she seems like the
right woman don't you guys want
it's about reputation you gotta hire
people based off their track record she
clearly has a love for cats that's all
that matters I don't think cats need cat
sitters though yes they do cat cats need
the at least 30 seconds of human
attention yeah I come through that door
oh and then they get the [ __ ] on with
their lives but they need yeah they just
want to boss people around your little
has been running out person Wow she has
a negative attitude towards the cats one
cat did me wrong so why were we in the
lair okay fine I don't want to be in
your guy's a relationship anyway
subscribe to Jess's channel which
features this thing
subscribe to my dog person
no and that's a good human being you
know that animals
are you sometimes you like cats that
fluffy cat I do like cats we can talk
about this for hours